our series a more perfect union
explorers how what unites us as
Americans is greater than what divides
us this morning we look at the value of
a picture that preserves a rite of
passage forever around three and a half
million students will graduate from high
school this year and many will spend
lots of money for a professional photo
to mark the big day Tony Duke opal is
here to show us what happens when a
family can't afford that priceless
memento Tony good morning good morning
our four years of high school often come
down to that single cap and gown photo
for the ages but the price of those
photos actually puts them out of reach
for many families which is why one
Philadelphia photographer has decided to
lend his camera to the cause pampering
has not been a big part of Denia Hinton
senior year in high school in fact most
of what's happened recently the 18 year
old would rather forget
alrightso family trouble car gets stolen
money's gone no vacation rain on prom
day and you're telling me it gets worse
it does because you know when you look
baking you look at your year and you
just think like wow like what memories
can you really say they were really good
professional graduation photos were
another memory she expected to do
without then emailing me Hayden a did
you miss something but god the water
your pitches and I'm like I didn't
forget the order nothing you couldn't
afford no but photographer Richard wah
had other ideas for denial and every
graduating senior who needed photo help
in Philadelphia have different stations
here I have a good friend of mine
karanji back in 1991 his family couldn't
afford graduation photos either a fact
he remembered recently when he saw a
photo of a young graduate on a bus well
really hit me was that he was by himself
you saw yourself exactly the
helplessness I saw no one back at home
or supporting him I didn't know what
having to take but I knew I was going to
do something about it
wahhhh decided to organize the photo day
he never had complete with makeup hair
and wardrobe a day like this would
typically cost hundreds of dollars but
while and his friends recently opened
their doors for
why not just do the photos why the whole
boat I want them to have the experience
I want them to know what it feels like
to feel special to have your hair done
your makeup done it feel like a king and
queen for today a sense of
accomplishment
like this is all you who done this we're
behind you Tania Powell brought her
godson Jaquan Williams this is a crazy
crazy blessing for our family and it's a
good picture I actually like oh that's
me
I don't like a lot of people they look
back when they were on high school why
they do not want to see their pictures
now and I would like to see more okay
after a year in which so much else felt
out of focus
Danae and her mother kelly finally got a
memory they want to keep what's going
through your mind right now dream come
true just let me give something back for
me cuz everything that take it from me
all you want I was senior year and
there's my deuces awsome tane it says
she plans to pick up at least two more
graduation photos someday one for
college and one for graduate school
Richard wah meanwhile snapped dozens of
free portraits that day including memory
didn't have his own
yeah his own 26 years after the fact oh
boy O'Day and Richard wah I mean it
shows you how much we take for granted
sometimes something as simple as a
graduation photo what it means to so
many also shows you how much those
photos have gone up in price of it yeah
I'm thinking a hundred hundreds of
dollars that surprised but aren't that
many opportunities of life to create
that much joy in that concentrated a
period of time I mean there are a lot of
very happy families that only took a day
but the picture lasts a lifetime
ok Tony thank you so much it's a great
story